they've driven the extremists out and
yesterday Iraqi soldiers celebrated an
end to the bloody struggle for Mosul
this victory always seemed inevitable a
few thousand Isis fighters pitted
against tens of thousands of Iraqi
troops and the full force of the US
coalition but it took nine months
because Isis fought to the death even in
the last days of the battle civilians
were forced to run the gauntlet of the
extremist snipers and suicide bombers
the Mosul offensive began in October in
farmland on the outskirts of the city
then in Christian towns long deserted by
residents where Isis had desecrated
churches finally Iraqi forces forged
into the heart of the city fighting
street-to-street laying waste to mosul
in order to reclaim it but as isis faced
defeat in mosul attention had already
shifted to rucker the so-called isis
capital across the border in Syria where
us-backed forces now have the extremists
surrounded we made it into Raqqa to
weeks ago and warped through eerie
neighborhoods silent except for gunfire
another city brought to its knees by
Isis and its cult of death and
destruction